so first let's start with a high five
like think about when in your life you
have either given or received high fives
what does a high five from someone else
or a high five that you're giving to
somebody else communicate you're on the
same team you're light up you give it to
somebody when their attitude's going
down come on keep going pick your
attitude up you give it to somebody in
celebration and so a high five
communicates support and empowerment and
partnership it's so powerful and we're
so good at giving all of those things to
other people and everybody especially
women we cheer for our friends we create
birthday parties we're so good at
cheering for our favorite musicians and
buying people's stuff we are horrendous
at giving that same support and
celebration to ourselves in fact we not
only don't give ourselves support and
celebration we do the opposite we tear
ourselves down and we beat ourselves up
and we pick ourselves apart and every
single woman I know is constantly saying
how the do I put myself first you put
yourself first by doing for yourself
what you've been doing for everybody
else because that's how everybody else
became first in your life hey it's Evan
Carl Michael and I make these videos
because when I started my first business
I really struggled to believe myself I
was making 300 bucks a month and quit on
my business partner and the thing that
saved me was watching the stories of
successful entrepreneurs they gave me
strategies as well as hope and belief
that just maybe I could do it myself as
well and I hope that this video here
today helps you get a little bit more
belief in yourself because I still need
the videos for myself today too so today
let's learn the unwritten life rules
that everyone should know enjoy
you need to start to cheer for support
and validate yourself period
I realize now that I'm high-fiving
myself
that I have spent
the first 40 years of my life either
criticizing my reflection or ignoring it
how sad is it
it's incredibly heartbreaking and yet ex
extremely familiar to me
yeah and I think a lot of women yeah
and believe it or not a lot of men
there's a lot of men that don't want to
look themselves in the eye in a mirror
and be with themselves because they're
so focused on the things that they
haven't achieved or the things that they
failed at and so they're ignoring
themselves they're not being with
themselves and so first things first
when you take a moment in the morning to
just stand in front of the mirror and be
with yourself
and then you raise your hand in a
gesture that you have always associated
with celebration support belief and
empowerment with other people there's a
number of things that happen that can be
proven by research first things first
this is research out of Harvard it's
recent they've shown in studies that
simply taking a minute in the morning to
get intentional about who you're going
to be today and how you're going to show
up changes your productivity it changes
your level of confidence it changes how
impactful you are as a leader at work
and in life so this moment in the mirror
is not to be diminished this is a moment
for you to be able to take a moment and
intentionally align yourself with who
you're going to be
second piece of research is from a field
of study called neurobics it basically
means when you marry a physical action
with something a thought that's
unexpected you accelerate the
development of new neural Pathways and
there's famous studies that have proven
that if you brush with like your
non-dominant hand while you're thinking
something it sticks in your mind because
you have to focus well the same is true
when you raise your hand and high five
your own reflection you see you've been
doing this for your entire lifetime so
there's already subconscious programming
here Lisa the second that you raise your
hand like this it is so programmed in
your mind to associate belief cheering
empowerment celebration you know with
the high five itself that it's
impossible to go God I hate my neck boy
is that cellulite ugly you can't do it
because this part of the mind
immediately takes over and does all the
positive stuff with a high five it's
crazy try it tomorrow morning you will
not be able to criticize yourself
now there's another piece of research
around this which is you know when you
do a high five we did one the first one
we did right we didn't quite hit each
other in the right like good smack so
what do we do we did it correct because
a good high five requires you to be
present and intentional
Isn't that cool
high five and so what I started to
notice was that I was in real time
shifting my relationship to myself
instead of criticizing the woman I saw
in the mirror or ignoring her I was
developing a partnership a trust
a sense of self-validation a I have my
own back I see you Mel Robbins we're
going to have a great day today we got
this no matter what it is that life is
going to throw at us you got this
that's how it all started and then of
course I put it on my story after a
couple weeks of doing it and people
around the world started to post them
pictures of themselves doing it and then
all of their stories started rolling in
about the difference that it was making
there was one woman that
said that she's been struggling with
dysm body dysmorphia for 20 years
cannot look in the mirror and after five
days of doing this can stare at herself
in the eyes with a grin five days five
days
and the reason why is because of the
lifetime Association
that you have with doing this for other
people so when you try this tomorrow
here's what I want
um you to do
stand in front of your bathroom mirror
and take a moment and just be with
yourself for a second and then if
there's resistance to raising your hand
and high-fiving your own reflection
what is that resistance and here's some
of the sad things that people are saying
that I think ring true for all of us I
think most women can relate to this I
think guys tend to have a reaction
that's more in the I must be weak if I
need this when the fact is if you've
played team sports you know damn well
that there's nothing more motivating and
there's no inspirational Force that's
more empowering than being cheered for
by your teammates that belief that they
have in you transfers to a belief that
you have in you and so we know
instinctively how powerful this is and
yet we have been trained to deny it to
ourselves that somehow if you have to
empower yourself you're weak
if you Empower yourself you're strong
you're smart and so with women and you
know with men too but I've found this to
be the case with a lot of women and this
is super sad that there is this belief
that if I've done nothing
that's worth celebrating I don't deserve
celebration
that I don't deserve celebration until I
lose the weight and get to that number
myself I don't deserve celebration until
I get that job until I'm dating somebody
until I buy that house until I get
through and that's the opposite of what
you actually need you need celebration
and support so that you can do those
things that you deserve and you want in
your life and so here you are
withholding the very thing that you need
support celebration love you're waiting
for somebody else to come Waltzing in
and give it to you which they're not
going to
and the secret to life is learning how
to give yourself the support the
celebration the validation that you as a
human being need
so that's one thing that women feel the
second thing is this idea that if you
are somebody that celebrates herself
you're a
right that there's something wrong with
you if you call attention to you and
that may be because your mom uh you know
kind of didn't call attention to herself
and was uncomfortable being the center
of attention maybe you got the messaging
that you needed to be seen and not heard
maybe it got reinforced in your family
that you're supposed to be the good one
or The Quiet One or the you know nice
one or the conscientious student or the
this or that that there was a role for
you to play and that if you stand there
and validate yourself that somehow it
means that you're not of those things
that other people need from you it's
complete and utter and let me
tell you why
when you were born
celebration
validation
all of that stuff was hardwired in you
literally when you were learning to
crawl you saw a mirror you would crawl
up to that have you ever seen a baby
order a mirror they like put their hands
on looking at them I love it it's
amazing love their face
that's in your DNA that's what you are
born you're born to love the sight of
yourself
your life trained you that you're not
supposed to do that
and so I'm on a mission to make
everybody on the planet understand
because this is both for men and women
it doesn't matter where you are in terms
of gender and what or all genders that
you identify with
every human being
has three fundamental emotional needs to
be seen to be heard and to be celebrated
for the unique person that you are
we all love watching these videos go
viral of uh caregivers coaching little
kids to be like I'm brave I'm awesome
I'm this and yet as an adult somehow we
think it's stupid to stand in front of a
mirror and tell that to yourself you
need to hear it and you're sad because
nobody in your life is telling you it
starts with you the other thing that
goes viral all the time are teachers
standing outside of classrooms right
giving every kid an individual handshake
why because that handshake alone makes
somebody feel seen and acknowledged and
supported and I'm here to tell you if
you want that and you do want that you
need it it is the most powerful source
of motivation on the planet to feel
those things it starts with you
and it can start every single morning
with a simple high five in the mirror
rule number two is use your ability to
create with Bob Proctor why is gold
creation an art that's an interesting
question and I think it's a question
that deserves an answer let's think of
this you and I are creators we have
creative ability we've been created in
God's image we've got faculties of the
mind that will change everything see the
art of gold creation is truly a creative
process the definition of creation is
the manipulation of energy you're
causing one type of energy to move to
another type of energy think about that
this Energy may never have moved in that
direction before until you came along
you play any new an enormous role in
your own life you can dictate where
you're going to go what you're going to
do you can control exactly what you want
to create in this life
goal creation is an art because we are
truly creating and that's why it's an
art
and you know one day Sandy Gallagher and
myself who is my business partner she
and I sat down and she said what we
should do is set a goal to create our
own TV station or set a goal to create
our own Studio where we could broadcast
all over the world and you know that
sounded so Preposterous when we first
sitted
but then we stopped without listening we
teach people that they can do things
that appear
Preposterous that we have this creative
ability and so we decided that's what we
do now right now I'm operating in that
studio it's a magnificent Studio I do
have cameras coming out of the ceiling
and then I have another camera where I
can be working here on this flip chart
and I can shoot that all over the world
so I can be giving instructions
regardless of where I am but what we've
also got
is something that's rather unique we've
got a green screen so you see in our
studio we can literally go anywhere in
the world and it comes right out across
the floor now we have built this place
and we built a um a control room here
John Scott who was our studio director
he can operate from here in this studio
or he could come in from anywhere in the
world and operate the studio from there
that's the way he's got the whole place
set up so you see we've got something
here that's rather magnificent and it's
built the way we wanted it because we
have the ability to create that's why we
call it the art of gold creation
there's no limit to what we can do the
men that built this studio his name is
Mike marandola he said he had never
built anything like this before where
they built the building and then they
built the studio inside the building
so that there's no noise from outside we
can completely cut off any sound from
outside it's what you call a floating
South why am i showing you this I'm
showing you this because we use what we
teach you see it's not an accident that
maybe just two or three percent really
reach their goals that is not an
accident most people don't go about the
goals the proper way see if you knew how
to reach your goal the goal isn't any
good you're going sideways goals are not
to get that's a side benefit me getting
this studio is a side benefit goals are
to grow it causes you to raise your
level of Consciousness I love what we've
created here Sandy and I look at this
place and we love it we absolutely love
it it's a marvelous place to work I get
up in the morning and I can come into my
studio and I can begin creating that's
how I want to live my life you can do
that get involved in the art of world
creation look at goals from a way you
never looked at them before
change your life I don't care where
you're at I don't care if you're broke
and you haven't got any idea how to get
to wherever you're going come to the art
of growth creation I guarantee your life
will change rule number three is trust
your intuition with Lisa Nichols
you know when you want to learn how to
trust your intuition more you know I say
and this is me and my walk and my my
belief system that your intuition is
your internal GPS system your internal
God placement system it's that whisper
and sometimes it's that scream that
tells you to LEAP or to be still your
intuition is a combination of spirit
emotion and logic
and it's guiding you and so often we
don't hear our intuition
why don't we hear it because we're
having too much chatter in our head
like the chatter in our head doubt worry
judgment oh my God judgment or fear fear
of other people's perception of you so
your intuition is saying I love to dance
I want to dance I want to sing your
intuition is saying we can have a great
time your intuition is saying I want
love your intuition is saying gosh let's
go take that chance on that writing that
book or let's take that chance on
starting that business then your chatter
comes in no what if I fail so let me
explain this to you your mind your brain
is designed to keep you safe
is designed and it only has the ability
to go back in time in the mental file
cabinet and look at the last time you
tried something like this and it may not
have been
um good or may have ended in some
dangerous situations uh where people
could judge you and your brain is
designed to protect you that's it your
brain desire to protect you it's logical
your intuition is that spark of passion
it's that spark of Desire
it's that spark of love it's that spark
of pull me forward it's that little bit
of radical it's that a lot of bit of
um of of I want to leave my fingerprint
on this planet your brain isn't designed
to have those same ideas now now your
intuition can kick the brain in and the
Brain can start thinking of ways too but
the intuition is where it's going to
start it's in your gut it's why when you
feel something you kind of go here you
don't go oh I feel so special you don't
say I feel special here you say I feel
it here I feel it here and so your job
is not to turn down the doubt your job
is to turn up the passion it's to turn
up the faith is to turn up the
possibility now still make well thought
out plans I always say the best plan is
the plan made I don't care if you have
to upgrade it you have to modify it but
if you if you if you
if you fail to plan then you plan to
fail
so every dream every passion every
desire follow it with a plan because
that's where your brain gets excited
your brain goes yeah we got a plan now
now you can believe yourself see you set
big goals and dreams and you have
desires and then you don't achieve it
but you don't achieve it because you
didn't set the plan in place you didn't
do the details and then you stopped
believing you could do it and then you
do the biggest tragedy you stop dreaming
you stop hoping you stop stretching
yourself you stop listening to your GPS
your God placement system that says
you've been put here on a Divine
assignment and your assignment may
change over years guess what your
assignment you had 15 years ago may be
very different from the assignment on
your life today
your job
is to turn down the volume in your head
the volume of judgment the volume of
fear the volume of worry the volume of
perfection turn down the volume in your
head and turn up the volume in your
intuition then your solar plex in that
God placement system in that heart space
turn up the volume in that place that
just says what do I want
what ask yourself this tonight today
tomorrow what feels good to my soul and
then be still and be quiet
I believe I believe in prayer and I
believe in meditation
and I grew up only knowing about prayer
but then I learned that prayer is asking
God or the Divine whatever you call your
god I've not been posing my belief
systems on you but I call them God that
prayer is asking God for direction and
meditation is being still and quiet long
enough to hear the answer
a lot of times we don't hear our
intuitive Spirit talking to us because
we're not still and we're not quiet
long enough to hear it
so give yourself the gift of quiet time
and really after you've asked the
question what brings me joy what excites
my soul what do I want to do for the
next six months or six years what makes
me feel passionate what sets me on fire
and then be still and then listen
but the biggest question
is will you be bold enough
to act on what you hear
I ain't going nowhere so I want to hear
what happens I want to hear what you
heard I want to hear what came up for
you I want to hear what sturge your soul
I want to hear how excited you got I
want to hear about the feelings that
begin to post through your entire body
when you listened to your GPS when you
listen to that calling in your soul I
want to know because that's when the
hair on the back of your neck stands up
that's when you get chicken skin that's
when you can't sleep at night that's
when you get up early I'm just saying
I'm just saying also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four is understand life with
Eckhart Tolle I'm not saying that you
should not
try to improve the conditions of your
life
but more importantly is to realize that
you do not
have a life because that's people say my
life now if you look at the structure of
that sentence my life
there's a duality there
because if you say my life that implies
that you have it it's mine
so it implies to Duality if you say my
life there's you and the life that you
have
it belongs to me it's mine
so this thought this language creates a
duality in your mind call it my life
that's interesting so there's me
and I have a life and then the fear
comes and if I have a life
I might lose it
and of course then you visit the
cemetery and you say yes they all once
had their life and they lost it they
lost their life
well that's going to happen to me too
not realizing
you are trapped in certain mental
formations
that create an illusory identity and
actually create
delusion
you don't
have a life because there is not a
duality without life there's no you
so you can't have it you are one with
life there isn't you and life
you are life
you can't you don't have it
now if you are it
you can't lose it because you can
because you are it
but of course we'll have to see more
deeply what we mean when I say you are
live but let's first moment stay with
that you are you are life you don't have
a life
you are I told you can say it for
yourself in your mind I don't I don't
have a life I am life
this is the end of duality
so you realize there's there's a Oneness
of you and life and when I say life we
can use another word
the essence of being alive
what is the essence
let's go there slowly what is the
essence of Who You of who you are what
is the essence
of the life that you are
okay now normal
humans which means
unawakened humans
say well the answer my life is my
whatever they identify with in their
it's my possessions my
what I have what I know what I
my body
all those things that I identify words
that see the essence of who I am is
whatever I derive my identity from
it could be the physical body but or it
could be my car
on my house or my work my function in
society
we could be
friends that I have things that I have
attained
it could also be
these things are all in the mind also
because when you're ident let's say
you're you're your sense of identity
which is
you compare yourself to others all the
time there's this you do when you're in
your mind you compare yourself to others
let's say your body
looks better than other people's body
for a while
these two will pass
[Music]
but for a while you can get in there and
then you become this is my body that
also is a mental formation so it's not
so much you identify with the body you
identify the thought of my body that's
what you identify you don't identify
with your
Ferrari if you have one it's the thought
of my car which is makes you Superior to
others who only have a little car
or your body makes you Superior to
others whoever puny and weak body
so you can display for a few years you
display your body on the beach
and feel good about yourself
and after a while
the day comes when you look in the
mirror
what happened
there's something wrong with the mirror
the in the past strength of the mirrors
that people made were so much better
than the mirrors now
so for a while you identify with this or
that that is
quite normal
and so when you ask who what is the
essence of who you are most people would
tell you
well I am this is who I am this is what
my identity is derived from this this
this and this and this bundle of things
is who I am it's not always positive
because I was just talking about having
a
body that looks better than other
people's body you could have a body that
looks worse than other people's body
and so that serves too you could either
either you look for something else that
gives you an identity like actually
you're more intelligent than all these
stupid beach bums
so you can say I just look at these
people so but you have so much more
knowledge and intelligence and you can
look down on them
or you can or you can be more spiritual
so if you I can't afford a Ferrari I'm
on my bicycle and you see look at this
materialistic person the Ferrari
so you can still or if that doesn't work
you can see how how unfairly treated by
life you have been and how much more so
much more miserable you are than most
most people
and you've really been a victim of of
circumstances you've been a victim of
your birth and of your your parents that
did a dreadful job with you
maybe if their parents had been more
conscious things could have worked out
but they weren't
so but that that also gives you a strong
conceptual identity so if you can't have
a positive one
the negative ones can be just as strong
if not stronger you can have a huge
victim identity
it's a favorite thing sometimes in the
collective certain egoic things become
fashionable for a while
nowadays is the victim identity for
certain groups of people are very
fashionable so people can feel oh yes we
have all been victimized by those people
and of course there's some truth in it
in some cases
but that doesn't
but to derive an identity
is a delusion to to
derive a sense of identity from that is
a huge delusion that is not who you are
that's all my life that's all
so if you are not all those things
so when I ask who are you
if I ask that question don't go let's do
this for a moment don't go into the past
can you can you
feel or sense who you are without
reference to the Past in you you don't
even need to remember your name right
now what for you don't really remember
your email address or your phone number
or what happened to you 10 years ago
don't need to remember that can you
still get a sense without reference to
your personal history
can you get a sense of beingness or
presence
oh
there's no past in that at all but what
is that
you can't really describe it all you
know is
that you are
I am rule number five is loosen up a
little with sad Guru what are the best
practices for someone who is dead
serious
dead or serious
well you referred to this last night
yeah
it once happened
there was a Sufi master in
Basra
Basra is that place which is famous for
pearls today in Iraq
or it's famous for bombing
whichever way
so
someone came and said
please give me a teaching he refused no
teaching
then more and more important people
started coming to him and said please
give us a teaching he said no teaching
now because he refuses to teach he
became very famous
so one day a great scholar in the area
who is well versed in all the scriptures
and everything he came and insisted you
have to teach
you have something that no scholar can
have I am beginning to realize that so
you have to teach you cannot keep it to
yourself
so
the Sufi Master looked at him and said
I am not giving a teaching to you not
because I am not willing because you are
not willing
The Scholar said what are you saying I
am not willing I am here I am asking you
I am the one who is asking you
and you're saying I am not willing
no the teaching that I give you will not
be willing
he said what is the teaching
are you willing
anything I am bullying
so
the master went inside brought a dirty
looking piece of cloth and gave it to
him and said wear this as your loin
cloth you take off all your robes and
nice clothes wear this as your loincloth
The Scholar looked at this dirty piece
of cloth said what this
not just that
then I will give you an empty can with a
string wear it around your neck
and I will give you a few sweets
peppermint
you go
on the street to the marketplace all the
young boys will look at you and tease
you and throw stones at you whoever
throws a stone at you take out a
peppermint green at them and give them a
peppermint
The Scholar said this is ridiculous what
will happen to me in this town if I do
such a ridiculous thing
see I told you you're not willing for
the teaching
because
the question is just this do you want a
teaching that you like or do you want
something that transforms you
that's a question
so now you're asking this question I am
dead serious
so the first and foremost thing is you
must make yourself
non-serious which is not possible so the
only way you can make yourself
non-serious is to be ridiculous
you know
can you do that can you get up and do a
jig right now
do it
foreign
way
the Indian jig
no no you must do the Indian jig
so you see you're getting little
non-serious now not dead at least still
serious Not Dead
so just loosen up your life a little bit
laugh a little more involve yourself
with people around you do things that
you think is not so important
don't do things which are very important
do simple things
it's very important you will do simple
things
very important things you're doing in
your life you will become dead serious
you know Bert and Russell an Englishman
Burton Russell said if you're beginning
to think that what you are doing is very
important you need to take a holiday
so holiday does not mean coming to India
foreign
holiday is every day in those 24 hours
you must take a holiday from your
seriousness
from yourself seriousness has come
essentially because of your
self-importance you hold yourself as an
important person
I want you to see you are like a speck
of dust in this existence tomorrow
morning if you disappear for sure in
India nobody will miss you
even down under
they won't bother much you know a
handful of people
they will also forget soon enough
isn't it so
nature does you're gone
and nothing will happen in this world
everything will happen wonderfully well
even if you're not there every human
being should be aware of this every
moment of his life it does not matter
what the whole world says about you it
does not matter how significant a work
you're doing you must understand that
tomorrow morning the world will go on
fine without you
whoever you may be isn't it so
if you constantly remind yourself of
this you will have no reason to be
serious
[Music]
definitely not dead
and don't be dead now a time will come
it's time to be alive and rule number
six the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is be in selfless
service with Jay Shetty when you've been
drowning in an ocean of material thought
and someone had the compassion and
empathy to reach down and grab you you
feel like you want to do the same thing
and and that's just my meditation
constantly you know you don't you can't
ever go back from that the amount of
gratitude I have for the people that
have invested in me
and I open up my eyes I was 18 years old
I would have gone down the path of
becoming an I probably if I had it my
way I probably would have wanted to
become an art director at a massive
company I probably would have done
pretty well for myself I would have
traveled the world and wasted my life
like that's I always think about that
moment of
sliding doors what could it be right and
that's what it would have been but
because I met these incredibly powerful
people who wanted nothing from me but
just to give it changed my life and
that's the opportunity I won
but it may not be a monk but when you
think like I'm On Cue you recognize that
actually am I exposing myself to as many
alternative methods of thought am I
really allowing myself to experience
everything the world has to offer
because if I'm not I'm already limiting
myself in a world that's actually
unlimited and that's the challenge I see
is that we are living at a time when you
have the most Choice available you have
the most experiences available but we
still put ourselves in these prisons
not only that those prisons are one of
self-seeking I mean you mentioned giving
I mean giving is is you know service is
the Cornerstone of this whole thing yes
being in selfless service to others yes
which is just counter programming to the
way entire you know our entire
infrastructure of Western Civilization
is constructed yes absolutely a complete
counter programming I remember when I
was giving a talk this was probably
about like
oh yeah probably about four years ago
and I was speaking to a group of
Executives and one of them came up to me
afterwards and he said how old were you
when you became a manga I was like 22
and he said when did you get the
realization that life was about selfless
service and I said well I'm still
getting there I'm not there yet but the
first time I fell in love with that idea
I was 18 he goes the first time I
realized that life was beyond me I was
42 years old when you know my child was
growing up and he goes that was the
first time I realized that life was not
just about me and I was thinking
when today like the reason why we're all
repeating messages and and continue to I
think remind people of these messages
that even ourselves is because you could
hear that life is about service a
million times but until you practice it
and until you really until you really
mold it into every area of your life
like this podcast is your service I
think we think of service also very
limited we think service means to go and
help a charity or being at the soup
kitcheners correct and that is beautiful
and people should do it it's it's
wonderful and I think we should all do
and I try and do as much as I can but
service is also serving through your
calling your talents your skills your
purpose that benefits other people and
it can be different like you know yeah
so yeah there's so many methods well the
ultimate is when you can find that thing
that lights you up and
channel that in a way to give back to
others and also support yourself and
your family and doing it I mean that's
the secret that's what this does for me
and I just feel like the luckiest person
in the world too yes you know live in
this time where this is possible and to
have kind of stumbled into this yeah for
sure there's a beautiful story that I
share that you've reminded me of now and
it's it's the story of two monks that uh
washing their bowls uh and while they're
washing their balls they see a one of
the monks sees a scorpion drowning and
so he helps the Scorpion out of the
water and puts it onto the side and in
that process he gets stung by the
Scorpion and the other monk says what
are you doing like you know this is
stupid he said don't worry about it
don't worry about it the Scorpion Falls
in again to the water the monk picks it
up again gets stung in the process and
puts it onto the side so the other
Monk's just like okay now he's just
being ridiculous like what are you doing
he said why are you saving the Scorpion
when you know that it's nature is to
sting and the monk replies goes I know
that the Scorpion's nature is sustained
but my nature is to save
and so he understood how hard wired his
service mindset was that he was willing
to go through the pain to act in that
way so what I'm trying to share with
that story is that we're all wired to
serve naturally as children as kids as
people as humans but we've been educated
for greed and you see this there's
countless viral videos of kids who like
walk up to their television screen and
wipe the cartoon characters uh tears off
with their tissues or like kids like
running to help the person next to them
and we were all once that person but
it's just the education that we get and
I'm not just too much school I'm just
saying generally the the education of
becoming self-centered and whether you
look at from a scientific point of view
the studies that have been done when
people help people their depression goes
down their mental health goes up when
people help people they're able to feel
more joy and experience more happiness
in their lives like we are happier when
we serve and help people
and that I think has been so lost that
if someone genuinely asks them so
because I think everyone hearing that
will say oh yeah but I like to help
people I try if you really did an audit
of how much time you spend every week
genuinely helping someone who is giving
you no help or was genuinely helping
someone who does nothing bad for you I'd
find that we'd say a very very little
amount of time yeah the key is doing it
when it's not convenient correct you
know what I mean yes exactly that's the
best way to say it yeah exactly
um
tough I mean listen you know you know it
it's not it's not just school it's like
by osmosis it's like I hear what you're
saying Jay that's great but like I gotta
get mine dude yeah you know times the
clock's ticking and time's running out
and I got my hustle on yeah so you want
my response to that sure yeah my
response to that is
that mentality
will get you the thing
and it will get you the number
and it'll get you the money in the bank
but you won't feel satisfied and that's
my hypothesis so go test it and I would
gladly let anyone test that and I
guarantee you that's how you feel what
happens though is you get it you have
that experience of momentary Elation
that quickly Fades the half-life on that
is very short and then you think your
next thought isn't I Need A New Path
your next thought is well when I get
that next thing exactly we're going to
lock in absolutely it's the hamster
wheel right it's it's the conveyor belt
and it
uh it's the treadmill that's the uh
that's the challenge with then I think
that's what we have to learn from people
who have got there and feel that way I
think we have to it's like you know when
you hear Jim Carrey say like everyone
should get everything they want and
become everything they ever wanted just
to realize it's not the point when you
see everyone who gets to the peak of
financial or fame or beauty success they
then try and serve like that's just what
everyone ends up having to do we're in
the world capital of that right here
yeah you know what I mean absolutely Los
Angeles and and you see it like you know
I I can't remember who said this but you
know it's it's talked about like your
success I can't remember who said it but
your success is based on the depth of
the problem you solve right and it's
like if you look at any success even if
it's Jeff Bezos and Amazon someone goes
I want to be Jeff Bezos Jeff has solved
not that I know him but Jeff has solved
a issue that people had so it's still
service and I think that's what we
missed that anyone who's winning even
financially whether we agree with their
business model or not they are
performing some type of service to
people and because he's serving more
people with an issue that they have he's
able to make more money so even from a
totally Financial perspective
service still wins like there's no
there's no you know there's no takeaway
it's a more it's just an expansive
definition of service correct correct
but but it's still so service ultimately
is is solving a problem that really is a
core need in people's lives and I think
that could be a starting point for
someone if they're still like Jay I
don't got it right I'm still I'm just
trying to yeah meet people where they're
the next best predictor of Lifetime
success is conscientiousness well so and
of the of the two aspects of
conscientiousness say orderliness and
and industriousness the better predictor
is industriousness so the question is
well what can you do about your
industriousness and the answer to that
is
well that's kind of rough too because
there's a strong genetic component but
you can work on micro habits with
regards to your conscientiousness and I
think the best micro habits this is
partly to do with this future authoring
program processes I think the best thing
you can do with regards to your
conscientiousness is to set up some aims
for yourself goals that you actually
value and the future authoring program
helps people do that and basically it
does a situational analysis of it helps
you do a situational analysis of your
life more than a psychological analysis
I would say and so so the questions are
something like well all right you're
going to have to put some effort into
your life
and you need to be motivated to do that
and so what are the potential sources of
motivation well you could think about
them in in the big five manner you know
if you're extroverted you want friends
if you're agreeable you want an intimate
relationship if you're disagreeable you
want to win competitions if you're open
you want to engage in Creative activity
if you're high neuroticism you want
security okay so those are all sources
of potential motivation that you could
draw on that you could tailor to your
own you know your own personality but
then there are dimensions that you want
to consider your life across and so we
ask people about well you know if you
could have your life the way you wanted
it in three to five years if you were
taking care of yourself properly you
know what would you want from your
friendships what would you want from
your intimate relationship how would you
like to structure your family what do
you want for your career well how are
you going to use your time outside of
your job and how are you going to
regulate your mental physical mental and
physical health and maybe also your drug
and alcohol use because that's that's a
good place to Auger down you know
because alcoholism for example wipes out
you know five to ten percent of people
so you want to keep that under control
and then
and then so maybe you know you you you
develop a vision of what your life what
you would like your life to be and that
Associates the so the goal once the goal
is established and then you break down
the goal into micro processes that you
can implement the microprocesses become
rewarding in proportion in relation to
their uh causal association with the
goal and that tangles in your your
incentive reward system you know we
talked about the dopaminergic incentive
reward system and that's the thing that
keeps you moving forward and the way it
works is that it works better if it
produces positive emotion when it can
see you moving towards a valued goal
okay well what's the implication of that
better have a valued goal because
otherwise you can't get any positive
motivation working out and so the more
valuable the goal in principle the more
the micro process is associated with
that goal start to take on a positive
charge and so what that means is well
you get up in the morning and you're
excited about the day you're ready to go
and so as far as I can tell what you do
is you specify your long-term ideal
maybe you also specify a place you want
to stay the hell away from so that
you're terrified to fail as well as
excited about succeeding because that's
also useful you specify your goal you do
that you do that in some sense as a
unique individual you want to you want
to specify goals that make you say oh if
that could happen as a consequence of my
efforts it would clearly be worthwhile
because the question always is why do
something because doing nothing is easy
you just sit there and you don't do
anything that's real easy the question
is why would you ever do anything and
the answer to that has to be because
you've determined by some means that
it's worthwhile and then the next
question might be well where should you
look for worthwhile things and one would
be well you could consult your own
temperament and the other would be well
you kind of look at how look at what it
is that people accrue that's valuable
across the lifespan look look what so
you do a structural analysis of the
sub-components of human existence and
already did that you need a family you
need friends like like you don't need to
have all these things but you better
have most of them family friends career
educational goals plans for you know
time outside of work
attention to your mental and physical
health Etc you know those are that's
what life is about and if you don't have
any of those things well then all you've
got left is misery and suffering so
that's that's a bad
that's a bad deal for you
so
so once you but once you set up that
that goal structure let's say and that's
really in many in many ways that's what
you should be doing at universities is
that's exactly what you should be doing
is trying to figure out
who it is that you're trying to be
right and you aim at that and then you
use everything you learned as a means of
building that person that you want to be
and
and I really mean want to be I don't
mean should be even those things those
things are going to overlap and it's
important to distinguish between those
because that's partly and this is back
down to the micro routine analysis so as
I saying well you're going to try to
make yourself more industrious okay
number one specify your damn goals
because how are you going to hit
something if you don't know what it is
that isn't going to happen and often
people won't specify their goals too
because they don't like to specify
conditions for failure so if you keep
yourself all vague and foggy which is
real easy because that's just a matter
of not doing as well then you don't know
when you fail
and people might say well I really don't
want to know when I fail because that's
painful so I'll keep myself blind about
when I fail that's fine except you'll
fail all the time then you just won't
know it until you've failed so badly
that you're done and that can easily
happen by the time you're 40.
so so I would recommend that you don't
let that happen so that's willful
blindness right you could have known but
you chose not to okay so once you get
your goal structure set up you think
okay if I can have this life it looks
like that might be worth living despite
the fact that it's going to be you know
anxiety provoking and threatening and
there's going to be some suffering and
loss involved in all of that obviously
the goal is to to have a vision for your
life such that all things considered
that justifies your effort change your
life you have to be willing to change
your actions
the definition of insanity is doing the
same thing over and over and over again
and expecting a different result
if you want to change your life you want
to be in a different spot you have to be
doing different things now if you love
your life great don't change anything or
you love pieces of your life don't
change anything about those pieces but
if you are not happy with where you are
at you must be able be willing to do
different things otherwise you will stay
stuck forever I was doing an Instagram
live yesterday with a young entrepreneur
he wants to be a speaker and he wants to
share his message and he's constantly
facing self-doubt and fear and
insecurity and nobody's watching the
stories and he's not good enough and who
am I to share a message in in our IG
live one of the things he said was
well I'm not I'm not comfortable doing
that
we're talking about making making
content some days he's on top of the
world and feels great and other days if
he's not and he doesn't feel comfortable
getting in front of the camera
and he started going off and telling me
a story stop right there
when you say
I'm not comfortable doing that
we have to identify that as a trigger to
go
saying I'm not comfortable doing that
now if it's against your values I get it
right you're not comfortable you know
I'm at Costco right now Nina's going
shopping in there I'm not comfortable
robbing Costco perfect okay that's
outside my value system that's totally
different most of the things that you're
not comfortable doing
are failing in front of other people
at the end of the day that's what it is
you're afraid of being judged and so
we're not comfortable doing that thing
you'll you'll fail if nobody else sees
it if it's just you but you don't want
to fail in front of other people and
that can no longer be a good enough
reason because if you only do think
about this if you only do what's
comfortable
you stay in your comfort zone
if you only do what's comfortable
and therefore you hate your life
because if all you did is wake up and do
what's in your comfort zone do what is
known do what is comfortable do what
do what you've always done you're gonna
hate your life and this becomes the
curse of a lot of entrepreneurs as you
know you're capable of more you know you
want to do more you know you have more
in your heart to go up and serve you you
want that you can you can see it you can
touch it you can taste it you can
visualize it's like I want to be there I
want to do that right has that happened
to you can that relate to you
you know you want more but you're afraid
to go off and do it and and you fall
back down to comfort at least
consistently you might have these
moments of greatness and boldness and
willingness to go do something but we
fall back down to comfort
and if you stay in comfort you will
never accomplish your great goals
because everything you want out of life
is on the other side of your comfort
zone
everything you want out of life
all your big goals your Big Dreams your
big Ambitions your mission the life that
you want the life that you want is on
the other side of your comfort zone and
so I had to stop him when he was talking
to me on the Instagram live because it
doesn't matter if you're not comfortable
doing it
is actually the opposite because you are
uncomfortable doing it now you have to
do it
because you need to train yourself that
you do uncomfortable things the fact
that you have accepted
being uncomfortable as a good enough
reason to stop is the big problem I
don't care what else you're gonna what
other Story You're gonna tell me
afterwards I have to stop the
conversation at that moment because I
could not allow him to continue with the
mindset of I'm uncomfortable so I'm
going to stop
and we all have these words that we tell
ourselves and we all have these stories
that we come back to as to why we're not
able to take action and the problem is
we believe those things and you need to
catch them and you need to root them out
and so for him that was the big aha
moment
that he needs to get uncomfortable and
it sounds
it doesn't sound like a big deal right
like oh of course you got to get
uncomfortable but what is the thing that
you're telling yourself as to why you're
not winning as to why you can't follow
through as to why you can't do the thing
and when somebody else shines a light on
it it's like it seems so obvious
and yet this is the thing that has been
holding you back and keeping you stuck
so I told him
anytime you hear yourself say
this makes me uncomfortable again as
long as it's not against your value
system right this makes me feel
uncomfortable
use it as a trigger to go forward
enlist your family he's newly married
enlist your wife enlist your parents
enlist your siblings anytime somebody
hears you say
that makes me feel uncomfortable that's
that's a trigger go have them have them
hold you accountable said you just said
it again now you got to go do that thing
it's not against your value system right
for me it's scary difficult and hard
I would accept
scary difficult or hard as good enough
reasons for me not to go off and do the
thing that I want to do
I want to make videos oh that's scary
like oh okay I can't do it
I've just accepted scary as a good
enough reason
and so if I never do things that are
scary I will never accomplish my big
goals
when um
you know when I when I was thinking
about doing my tour in 2019 when we hit
23 cities 90 days
I thought that was too difficult
too difficult you know like I'm I was
afraid to get on stage and here I am not
facing my fear every four days in a new
city I've never done a tour instead of
just doing a small tour of three cities
or something like 23 cities 90 days you
know a quarter of the year on the road
straight with with my wife and my
cameraman
okay let's go
because I do difficult things because I
want to train myself that I do difficult
things
because again my dream life is on the
other side of me doing difficult things
if I only do what's easy
I'm gonna eventually hate my life
this is where we get stuck
you know when you do something that's
easy
and you win you win a little Ribbon or
an award right you you run a race
against three-year-olds and you win
congratulations amazing you won and you
could post about on Instagram and you
had this little moment of Accolade but
you don't actually feel good about
yourself because you didn't do anything
difficult because that was easy for you
the self-love self-confidence
self-respect comes from doing difficult
things
uncomfortable things scary things hard
the willingness to show up even if you
don't win
because it's difficult and challenging
that's how you ultimately will win in
life
and start to accomplish your goals and
so
most people are photocopying their lives
this is this is where most people are
stuck you're photocopying your life
today look the same as yesterday look
the day is the day before same as the
day before is why most people do not
like their life is why most people drive
to a job that they hate
they're driving to a job that hey most
people wake up all you know look at all
these cars here most people here in this
parking lot they're picking up every day
and driving to a job that they hate they
do not like their life most of the
people who are telling you what you
should do with your life do not like
their own life
and so the answer is to catch your
trigger words so I call them play bigger
triggers
what's a play bigger trigger what are
your trigger words what do you say think
about one of your goals
you know think about what's on your list
of to-do's think about where you want to
be you know what do you have to get done
what's one of your most important goals
right now that you've been
procrastinating on
what have you been delaying on there's
something
everybody's got something what's the
goal of yours that you've been sitting
on and then what's the voice in your
head that that's giving you an
acceptable reason for you not to do the
thing
now try to get to the reason behind the
reason
so example somebody wants to make
YouTube videos I want to I want to be a
thought leader I have a message in my
heart I want to get it out to the world
awesome what's the reason why you're
telling yourself you can't do it like oh
well I know the time I don't have the
camera I don't have the gear I don't
have the microphone I don't know what to
say uh all of these those are the
practical reasons right those are not
the real reasons the real reason is
buried underneath the Practical reasons
why do you think that having the right
camera and microphone is going to be the
difference well because you're actually
afraid of judgment you're afraid that
people are going to watch it
we're afraid of one people won't watch
it and what does that mean you know that
you suck and the people will watch it
and laugh at you or criticize you for
having a bad phone bad camera bad
microphone
or they can't hear you or whatever else
like you're afraid of judgment
underneath the reason of
I don't have a good enough camera
microphone Etc
is just fear
and the fear specifically is judgment
so think about your own goals
what do you want to do what have you
been delaying on what have you been
procrastinating on what's the reason
you're telling yourself
The Logical one the one that you're
buying and then what's the reason
underneath the reason
what's the actual reason
and that's your trigger
so if it's fear of judgment if it's fear
of failure if it's fear of not being
good enough if the fear of being
imposter if it's fear of being
uncomfortable whatever your actual fear
is that's your trigger
and that is holding you back not just in
this one goal but in life in everything
in all your goals it's the reason why
you're not taking action across all your
goals
and so now when you can catch it
and then take the action to say I am the
person who does difficult things I am
the person who gets uncomfortable I am
the person who's going to change my
actions because that's the only way I'm
going to get the life that I want
when you can catch it specifically
it shortcuts the brain
because at least for me and I've seen it
work for many other people when you've
when you've accepted comfort for example
as a reason why you can't take action
and then you hear yourself say well that
makes me uncomfortable
now you have to do it you just have to
do it
you take the brain out of the equation
now the reasons don't matter
you said uncomfortable so now I have to
go and do it period
so catch what your trigger word is and
I'd love to even know in in the comments
below if you want to leave what is your
trigger word that when you say it when
you text it when you think it when you
feel it that has been holding you back
and that you no longer wanted to
so let's put it in the chat and let's
relieve
a little bit of that pressure that that
word holds over us
so you can actually go build the life
that you want some of you've done so
much work to get out there to finally
catch the wave anybody ever caught a
wave in business or a wave in the ocean
for that matter you catch a wave in the
ocean you know what that's like a
perfect wave or a good wave all of you
probably done at least a little one and
it's almost inexpressible isn't it it's
an incredible feeling you're kind of
connected to God and the ocean and
yourself in those moments and it's just
a wonderful journey and these waves can
take you places you would ever otherwise
never get without them and you can get
there faster also true in business you
gotta paddle and kick and scratch and
Claw and move and you're using things
you've never used before you're you're
finding assets you have that you didn't
even know you had to get out there then
you catch these waves in business and
it's wonderful and it can take you
places and it feels a certain way it's
never felt before and many of you caught
waves I'm sure you've caught a wave in
business in the past or multiple ways
some of you probably even got some
pretty darn big ones well let me ask you
a question
what if when I got out there I started
to say to myself well you know heck I've
caught three or four of these waves this
is pretty darn good I could probably
float and I'll probably just keep
catching them if I float but would I
well you know I wouldn't what would
happen if I stopped completely moving my
arms and legs
kicking and paddling
I'd sink
if I'm not careful if I don't do it long
enough I could drown and I see that
happen all the time in business see in
my business the paddling and the kicking
and the swimming is recruiting and
developing people leadership sales
skills running a system in a particular
way those are the things that are the
paddling and the kicking and prospecting
in my business in your business it may
be something different but nonetheless
I'm not immune to the laws of nature if
I sit in that ocean and I stop moving I
stop paddling and kicking and doing what
you got to do I won't float I'll sink
I'm not immune to the laws of the ocean
nature the universe gravity you name it
and neither are you I'm also not immune
and nor are you to the laws of business
The Laws of Success The Laws of Success
say if you stop doing those things you
don't float you never grow or you never
just stay the same in business you're
either growing or dying you're either
sinking or swimming I want you to be
swimming I want you to be riding Waves
by the way the bigger the waves the
harder you gotta work to go catch them
but what most people do in business is
they fall in love with a delusion or the
illusion of the fact that I can stop at
some point I've seen people stop quickly
in my business a couple weeks into the
business either get an award for
bringing the most people to the meeting
oh I can stop kicking and paddling now I
can stop calling people and seeing
people and I see them sink I've seen
people a year or two later get a
promotion to a certain level and they go
oh now I can stop paddling and kicking
and I'm going to float and keep riding
these waves and I've seen them sink and
sometimes I've seen them drowned
and that's a sad thing to see someone
drown and go out of business just simply
because they fell in love with the
illusion and the lie that they can float
and stop moving I've seen it happen five
years in 15 years in 20 years in a
million a year two million a year you
name it I've seen it when they've
developed a bunch of people when they
have it you'd say well yeah that's not
true I mean not everybody sinks I mean I
have friends heck in my own business too
they've stopped paddling kicking and
they still ride a wave or two here and
there and they're pretty happy
really
are they really happy will they ever
know what it would have been like to
ride the biggest and best waves of their
life the answer is no if you stop
paddling kicking you'll never know where
you could have gone
more importantly you'll never know who
you could have become see the people who
paddle and kick forever and make that
decision they've got a chance to become
the highest version of themselves the
highest expression of themselves which I
think is what life's about see the
champions in Fitness in faith in the
water in every area of Life make a
decision early that they are about the
paddling and kicking because that's the
ticket to the biggest the next and the
biggest waves of life life isn't about
catching a few and stopping life's about
the next wave ask any Surfer they're
chasing the next big wave they're
chasing the grave one and once they
catch that they want to chase another
one because it's about being out there
it's about being in the game it's about
riding the big waves it's about finding
the highest version and expression of
you and I want to challenge you to do
that in your business I want to
challenge you to see the great ones
decide see the average they they look
for reasons they look for reasons to
stop paddling kicking oh now I can oh
now I can see the Champions don't want
those reasons the Champions want to keep
paddling and kicking to ride the big one
The Great Wave of their life
can only get better if you'll keep
paddling and Kicking please don't stop
please don't fall in love with that lie
and know the truth that the winning way
is the way to keep paddling and kicking
you're not about floating you're not
about sinking you're not about drowning
you're about riding the biggest waves of
your life in the future and whatever
area matters to you whether it's your
faith or your family or your Fitness or
your business make the decision that
you're going to do the things that's
required to ride the next big wave and
it will take you places you can't even
imagine I know you all have big goals
Big Dreams big aspirations just like I
do you've got Ambitions to become an
amazing person to build your career to
create contribute to give to be an
awesome human being but all of that is
impossible without great habit set up if
you don't have routine and structure set
up in a way that will keep you on track
then you'll you'll fall off and and
having new goals without new habits is
kind of like you know having a new car
without wheels you know the habits are
the wheels they're the things that make
you able to achieve the goal holes so
you got to have good habits but the
challenge for most people isn't that
knowledge I mean you know you need to
have good habits it's you can't keep the
Habit going right have you ever started
it the new year you're going to get
healthier and you start that habit of
working out more on a more regular basis
and then it goes away or you say you
know I'm going to be more kind and more
patient and more awesome to my partner
my lover and you start being nice for
two or three days and then on the fourth
day you're a jerk you know and you're
like why what happened I said I was
gonna be nicer it's that you didn't set
up the most important thing you needed
to maintain a habit so what's the
biggest secret I've learned in almost 20
years in this field it's so simple but
most people don't have it it's called
trigger moments you have to set up
trigger moments to activate your habits
what do I mean by that well let's say
you want to become a better person you
know you want to become more kind more
patient more loving with people now you
can just set that intention or write
that down in your vision in your journal
or set up on a vision board that you
look at once in a while but in
day-to-day life it's not enough you need
things to trigger you to remind you to
be that particular kind of person right
it's almost like if you could have a
little angel speaking in your ear all
day long to tell you what to do and how
to be you'd obviously become better well
that makes sense well let's use that
idea let's use that idea by setting up
alarms on our phones that trigger us to
do the very things we need to do this
can be so basic you're going to laugh
and then also tell you how I literally
taught this to Fortune 50 CEOs and they
said it was the one thing that changed
their life the most dramatically so
let's start with this let's I have a
goal in mind let's say you want to
become more present and calm throughout
the day again you could write that down
on a journal I'm going to be more
present and calm you can meditate in the
morning saying today don't be more
present and calm and you're you could
you could start out with good intentions
but those fall apart without a trigger
moment set up throughout the day to
remind you that so what if you did this
what if you just set up on your phone
three alarms during the day with a label
that said
close your eyes
take 10 deep breaths in remind yourself
to be calm
so let's say you're going through your
day it's crazy right it's 10 a.m and
also Bing your phone goes off you look
down and it says close your eyes take 10
deep breaths and then again it happens
at two o'clock and again it happens at 6
pm and again it happens at 8pm what's
gonna happen you always look at your
phone don't you it's going to go
throughout the day you're going to
forget and the funniest thing is I've
had so many people do this worldwide
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of people I've taught to do
this hundreds of thousands and they tell
me all the time that changed everything
and you'll think once you set it up that
the next day you you'll you'll forget
about it no that alarm will go off you
forgot you set the dang alarm there it
goes off in your face you're like all
right I'm trying to be calmer and more
present close my eyes take 10 deep
breaths re-ground myself here we go
you can't do it once a day you have to
have moments throughout the day that
trigger you to enact the new Behavior I
know this makes sense to you but it's a
challenge for a lot of people because
they never set those things up so what
if you did it with an alarm
so for example for me on the opposite
Spectrum I don't want to just be calmer
and more present I Want More Energy
throughout the day so here's what I do
one of my big trigger moments is every
time my butt hits a chair I don't care
if I'm on a plane or I was like where
we're shooting here I I wrote a lot of
my books here I wrote the motivation
Manifesto here I wrote The Charge here
and if I'm going to write my butt hits
the chair I grab my phone I open the
timer and I set 50 minutes
now at 50 minutes the timer goes it
starts buzzing and I look at that and I
go oh that's my trigger to get energy so
I stand up I go get some water I take a
glass of water drink it down I do some
stretches and I do some exercise just
really briefly or I'll go for a walk
whatever it is but I'll do something
that usually takes just two to five
minutes then I'll sit back down I'll set
that 50 minute alarm and I'll work
and what that does is every 50 minutes
it triggers me to change how I'm
physically moving it changes my
attention so that throughout the day I'm
continually refreshed so I never have
that two three four o'clock time where
I'm like ah you know why because I'm
triggered my day so that my energy is
maintained throughout the day makes
sense right this could be as simple as
let's say you want to be healthier in
your life okay let's set up some trigger
moments for you in this way let's say
every time you drop off the kids on the
way back to the house you stop at the
grocery store and get some fresh produce
that's just a trigger it's like okay did
one thing drop kids off now tied to that
triggered from that action drop kids off
is go to health food store or let's say
you want to get healthier in the morning
one of the easiest ways to help people
maintain a better exercise program is
this
set a trigger you wake up in the morning
your first action is to drink water put
your exercise shoes on uh might get
dressed if you were naked just saying so
you get dressed put your shoes on you go
downstairs or you go to the gym and
that's the trigger you woke up you do
these actions nothing interrupts those
actions that's the action and you have
to have those set up one of my other
favorite trigger moments to set up is
door frame triggers what do you remember
that when you walk into a new room to
have a psychological trigger go off in
your mind that you've associated with
that door frame so let me give you an
example if I walk into my house at night
after if I've been working all day and
I'm going to walk in I'm gonna see my
lady I have it so when I ever walk
through the doors of my house three
words repeat off immediately in my mind
because I've done it so many times
consciously I went to the door I said
the three words said three words said
the three words and I did this so many
times and now now when I walk through a
door my mind automatically triggers
those three words and I remember to be
those three words so what words would
you love to have describe you as a
person that you would be happy if that
was how people described you what would
those words be
have those and now set them up in your
life I teach Executives to do this as
well I have them have a door frame
trigger when they walk into their office
in the morning as soon as they walk
through that door frame they have boom
three words go through their mind about
how they want to be perceived as a
leader I have them set up another door
frame every time they walk into a
meeting into the conference room when
they walk through the doors of the
conference room they have another three
words that trigger off for them and it
just reminds them how to be
so these aren't big crazy things a lot
of people think they have to completely
change their life what would change your
life completely is setting up more
trigger moments and associations that
when you see something you do this that
when this action is taken then that
happens that when you uh have the
opportunity to set up alarms on your
phone you set them up so that you're
interrupted in your everyday life to
remind yourself to stick to the habits
to stick to the intention you do that
enough on a continual basis you'll find
yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want some incredible success motivation
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there here's the hard
truth about getting great it takes time
and dedication it takes a willingness to
accept that you're not yet good enough
it takes the ability to stare at the
places that you know that your week